on a rocky beach in Iceland two
youngsters are on a mission of mercy
inside their cardboard box they have two
orphans fledglings plucked from the
streets of town baby puffins the
children of Jemez have been saving young
puffins called couplings for generations
in fact at the end of the summer
releasing them by the hundreds to the
safety of the sea has become a local
tradition
[Music]
you have to save the birds well if you
don't deal with a die they find it very
exciting exciting obviously for the kids
you get to throw live birds into the air
and watch them fly away but no doubt
it's a little nerve-wracking for the
recently born puffins the problem for
the public is that when they are old
enough they leave their burrows in the
clips and head out to sea but the lights
of the town use them instead of flying
out to sea they fly into town where they
crash land and end up on the streets
that's where the puffing patrols come in
each night during the month of August
moms and dads the troops of kids in town
will pay for wayward cufflinks they use
flashlights to search the ground near
buildings and streetlights
the pier is a particularly popular place
when a bird spotted the kids rushed to
scoop it up and bring it in off the mean
streets of hamate for the night
[Music]
it's hard work the following day all the
birds that landed in friendly hands are
transported to the seashore pointed in
the right direction and given their
flying orders the kids seem to be having
a great time apparently there is a
proper way to release the puff wings
first the proper grip then the right
technique with his wings free and
flapping the ideas to your arm like
a quarterback and throw a short pass
whether they swim to safety or fly off
over the North Atlantic one wonders what
kind of impact all this has on the
species as a whole the world's largest
Atlantic puffin colonies are found in
Iceland containing some eight to ten
million birds they're still flourishing
with a little help from some strong arms
and big hearts
[Music]